how you doing everybody it's movie
retrospective time once again
doing a weird ass one today
yeah man who's fell to earth the man who
fell to earth i was actually kind of
excited to see that they had added this
one on we watched it on amazon prime
right it's on amazon prime like if you
have amazon prime you can watch it for
free i've never seen the uncut version
this is like an uncensored this is yeah
because i think i saw this there's a lot
of nudity out of the one that i saw they
did well honestly like when i looked it
up because the version i saw i saw this
probably when i was in my late teens or
early 20s and i was like wow that was a
weird ass movie because like i said i
was really into david bowie kind of a
downer actually i wanted to see it yeah
so it's like a really weird movie but i
remember kind of liking it and i was
like oh we need really need to revisit
that now the version that i saw back
then and i think the version that was
making the rounds like theatrical was
the theatrical cut and it's actually
like 20 minutes shorter probably better
than
uh not really because i think that the
reviewers at the time
um
if you think like the uncut one which is
you know two what is it two hours and 20
minutes or something like that yeah um
yeah it's 140 minutes if you think the
uncut one is like incomprehensible
uh from what i hear the theatrical cut
is even more incomprehensible because
they take like a lot of stuff out
so
is so the
so the one that they have on amazon
prime now is actually like the
director's cut the the full cut one um
but i think that originally i saw it
in its cut version which had 20 minutes
trimmed out of it which was mostly like
i said i'm pretty sure
that one scene near the end which we'll
get into i'm pretty sure that was part
of what was taken out but they must have
taken out more than that because that
wasn't 20 minutes long but yeah so
this okay back stories to the supporting
characters which you don't really have
to know like that's true dude begging
all the young students all the 18 year
olds you don't really need to know that
there's a bunch of [ __ ] you don't need
to know you don't need you don't need to
know the backstory
of the cia guy you know you just
you could tell this is adapted from a
book
because it would have played better in
the book but it doesn't movie very well
um kind of like how dune doesn't make a
good movie
not you know if it to make dune right it
needs to be like a trilogy of movies
which is i think what they're going to
do now at least two
and
this was read this is meant this story
is meant to be told in novel form you
can tell although i haven't read the
novel like the the novels by walter
tevis that came out in 1963
from what i've heard uh the movie
adaptation isn't all that similar to the
novel um i don't even know if i'd go so
far as to say it was just like an in
name only adaptation but from what i've
heard um the movie and the novel really
don't have much to do with one another
other than being like the very same gen
like i mean other than it being like
just very general
you know generally uh the same plot but
you know if you didn't know so this was
directed by uh nicholas roig who you
know is a very arty farty kind of
filmmaker very experimental filmmaker um
probably best known for don't look now
which is one of my favorite horror
movies that came out in 1973 and uh he
did performance with mick jagger which i
saw a long time ago but i'd have to like
rewatch that one too this one came out
in 1976
and it's interesting because david bowie
being in this
this was really before
david bowie this is david bowie's first
acting role like he had been trying to
get into acting uh but he wasn't like a
mega star at this point and i know that
if you didn't grow up in the 70s like
maybe it's hard to imagine that now
because david bowie is like everybody
knows david bowie but back in the 70s he
was still this was a an era where he was
still kind of
he was known but not yeah i mean
david bowie didn't get famous until the
very early 80s when the let's dance
album came out yeah yeah when you had
let's dance and yeah modern love that's
really where he became a household name
before that time only people who who
were kind of connoisseurs knew who knew
who david bowie was yeah but he was way
ahead of his time i mean you know even
in this movie he does a lot of [ __ ] that
is ahead of his time the way he looks
and what he's wearing
um
he was almost kind of like the original
cosplayer in a way he would dress up as
things
he faked his way into being a damn rock
star his first
big album was about a dude who wanted to
be a rock star and he just kind of faked
it until he made it
because he was extremely talented and he
was good looking everybody's really good
looking and he had a really good well i
wouldn't say good looking he was he was
magnetic because he looked so alien but
he looked good oh yeah
and he had really good taste in things
fashion and clothes and stuff
especially for his time
and uh on the back of his talent
and on the back of his ability to down
play people too
um he built an empire and one of the
richest guys one of the richest guys in
music to have ever lived
and he didn't make that movie and music
he made it in real estate
i mean and art but you know
art dealing is a euphemism for
laundering other people's money but
but uh yeah
he's cool dude real cool died a couple
years back and i was a
big fan of all of his albums listen i
listened to all of them yeah his empire
was you know built on the back of who he
was as a person yeah and um
this idea that wait a minute david bowie
making movies and he's he wanted to be
an actor before he even wanted to be a
musician he never really considered
himself to be a musician because he
always considered himself to be an
entertainer
yeah
and he primarily wanted to be an actor a
lot too you know he even wrote songs
about a cracked actor and stuff you know
and his shows were kind of
had a lot of cosplay and he would adopt
new identities like the thin white duke
and ziggy stardust and
he was an original and he he was the
first to do that kind of [ __ ] well
honestly i think that nicholas rohit got
the idea to put him in this movie
because he wasn't the first choice uh
for this role um but i think from from
seeing uh you know cracked actor that
kind of stuff so so he knew that even
though he wasn't a massive star i kind
of feel like
i think paramount wanted to make like
made this and i think that they gave it
to nicholas roig on the strength of
don't look now which was actually like a
really big success
um and this was not it's but i feel like
nicholas rogge was like he wanted to
make a movie because you know how this
movie is kind of like
this is one of those movies that it's
like it's it's either like a sci-fi
masterpiece or you it's just gonna be
like incomprehensible or i guess it
could be both of those things it is
incomprehensible in some ways but
nicholas roig
wanted to make this
where it was kind of like
he wanted to play with the conventions
of film he didn't want to make a
standard narrative film with like a
timeline and like things happening
in like you know what i mean because the
one thing that really like struck me
about re-watching this movie is that it
it gives you no clue whatsoever really
about how much time is passing it's just
kind of jumping around in time and place
um and they're not really telling you
how much time
is going by
and i think he wanted to do that because
he wanted it to be seems sort of like
unmoored from reality or from linear
time chances are you were dropping acid
when you were seeing this movie anyway
yeah it was really big on like the
midnight movie circuit yeah um so and
you can totally see why because some of
the i mean i think it's it's not as if
you see it now
it's probably not as like weird or
experimental or something like that as
it would have been in the 70s like in
the 70s it was probably like whoa
like so crazy it's like it's detached
from the space-time continuum you know
what i mean so i i feel like that's kind
of what he was going for this is
definitely an art film oh definitely
definitely she's saying that it's it's
kind of incomprehensible it you can
comprehend it yeah it has a plot it has
a plot it's just that it's its structure
and its edit is kind of ponderous
it's jumping around and it's not telling
you how to feel about certain things
it's just showing you certain things
like his relationship with his
girlfriend it's just a pretty standard
superficial relationship but they've
known each other forever and it just
makes you wonder
is this supposed to be some kind of a
deep and meaningful relationship or is
it just supposed to be no official
relationship it is supposed to be
what it was well because that's kind of
the whole theme of the story
is that you know he's the man who fell
to earth he's an alien in case you
didn't know who comes to earth and ends
up falling into the vapidity
of sort of like corporate
america um you know wealth accumulation
uh you know just vapid entertainment
empty relationships and he just
alcoholism and he just ends up getting
sucked into it he becomes like pink
floyd from the movie the wall in a
certain way yeah it is kind of like that
it is kind of like kind of like that and
it's it's kind of a downer because he
starts off as an interesting character
but then towards the end he's kind of a
mundane failure he failed in his mind
but that was the whole point that was
the point of the book and that was the
point of the movie as well not only did
he fall to earth he fell to mun
to reality and being mundane
which i guess that's how the author felt
at the time and that it's kind of to me
it felt like an analogy for being a
teenager in a way where some teenagers
have these big [ __ ] idealistic views
i'm going to change the world i'm going
to [ __ ] help people and just change
everything to be revolutionary but then
reality starts setting in it starts
kicking your ass yeah and it doesn't
turn out that way and uh yeah that
people lie and that uh
you're not original other people have
tried to do that and the fact you're
just like everybody else you know that
kind of [ __ ] starts kicking in the end
you're just looking
swilling vodka and yeah [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah i got a job yeah i'm making money
and uh and he was a billionaire
billionaire in this movie he ended up
having all these patents and [ __ ]
changing
society
and putting out all these [ __ ]
disruptive technologies he ended up
being kind of like a elon musk type dude
um
made all this money but it still wasn't
enough it was just vapid [ __ ] really
and uh the cia [ __ ] saw him as a
threat because he was putting out
disruptive technologies that was
threatening other [ __ ] oligarchs and
threatening the [ __ ] normal order of
[ __ ] planned obsolescence so they had
to [ __ ] capture him and they didn't
believe he was an alien there's all
kinds of [ __ ]
it's an interesting movie in a certain
way
it would have been a lot better with a
modern tight edit and edited this [ __ ]
down to like an hour and a half probably
and
and it could have been done a lot better
by today's technology but it is a movie
of its time and it's on the [ __ ] back
on the strengths of david bowie
if it wasn't david bowie this movie
would have been forgotten he's real good
in it so we're the other k actors
they're all yeah
i kind of feel like what ended up
happening like i said this is david
bowie's first acting role now according
to him he was totally coked up like
during this whole thing but he said that
that kind of worked out good because he
didn't really have any idea what he was
shooting from day to day so he wasn't
really acting he was just acting like
himself okay yeah and he's like so that
can't kind of came across very well
because he cut he comes across as like
just a real
like a almost like a howard hughes type
where he's just kind of like real
reclusive and secretive and he's like
very soft-spoken well hughes was like
this they probably yeah as a model maybe
but yeah so the story of it and like i
said there is a story there is a plot
it's just this is a very strange
i mean it's it's kind of like the
apotheosis of the like the 70s
experimental we're shaking up like how
film making like linear time and all
this other kind of stuff so i see what
he where he was going with that but it
does have a plot that you can follow
it's just
it's just it doesn't really like hand
hold you as to like how much time is
going by yeah so essentially in the at
the very beginning they show you know
some kind of stock footage kind of stuff
of like space and everything so you're
meant to presume that he's you know come
to earth there's a big splash he falls
in the water now you don't know how long
it's been because it seems like he shows
up in a town and i think it's like in
new mexico
and i'm pretty sure that's where they
shot it like around albuquerque and
stuff and he shows up and he sells a
ring to get money and like the lady only
gives him twenty dollars but then later
he has like a big roll of cash so you
don't know how long it's been if he
brought cash with him somehow from an
alien planet or if there was like some
kind of cash exchange on the planet he
came from i don't know but his whole
mission
is that he has a wife and kids back on
whatever planet he came from which i
don't think they ever name
um and their their planet is having like
a really bad drought and so he was
tasked apparently um by somebody
to come to earth
yeah maybe because it doesn't look like
anybody's communication with his wife
remember he's just talking to his wife
and it didn't look like there was many
people on the planet that might have
been they might have been the last of
them yeah yeah it could like i said
there's a lot of stuff is just left
vague
so he just comes to earth either to
bring water back to his planet or to see
if this planet is like okay and can the
rest of the family come there although
i'm assuming that he was supposed to
take water back to that planet yeah and
they didn't think that's what i was much
evidently because they were recycling it
you see it in their little suits so yeah
i don't think i think he
i think really he was only planning on
bringing back a few gallons of it which
is that strange but that's like man i
have to drive all the way back to earth
like to go get water
but yeah so but that's what he was
tasked with
so he comes there and because he has all
this cool ass alien technology like he
has um self-developing photographs which
i think is funny it's like that's not a
big deal now but in the 70s that was a
big deal um he had like those kind of
communication devices which are almost
kind of like those roll up
screens like they have now like the yeah
but they were kind of holographic but
they were like holographic he has those
he he so he has a bunch of stuff and
he's able to just go to this one
he's a patent lawyer right that guy or a
corporate lawyer and he goes to him and
he's like look i want to make you the
president of this company i'm setting up
i have all these patents i have all
these cool like techniques i want you to
start the business and like i'm just
only going to talk to you about it and
he makes essentially like billions and
millions of dollars like immediately so
like i said there's they don't there's
no like build up it's just kind of like
in the next scene he's got he's got this
comp huge company and it's global yeah
and these businesses these companies
that he has that what they're doing is
they're making enough profit so he can
have his own private space force yeah
and then and
that spacecraft is going to go back to
his planet that's how he's going to
bring the damn um
uh
that's how he's going to bring the water
back to his planet using yeah
so that's that's the plan yeah he's
because well when he goes to the guy
he's like well how much do you think
these patents will be worth and i think
the guy says like 300 million dollars
and dave david well david bowie's like
that's not enough and the dude's like
bro how much do you want yeah and then
so i was thinking oh he's he wants to
build he wants to start his own space
program so he can go back and forth so
he can take water or bring his family
there or whatever it is that he's doing
um
so yeah so that's why he needs to like
uh do all this kind of uh [ __ ] but as
that happens it's like the so it gets
like really successful he makes [ __ ]
tons of money um he's very like i said
very reclusive he only basically talks
to that one dude um and it's weird too
because there's all these kind of like
side characters that eventually end up
like working for the company or working
against the company or working against
the company but i mostly talked about
like that professor dude and like that
other guy the professor and the lawyer
um yeah like the professor like i said
there's this whole side i don't even
know if i'd call it a side plot because
it's not really a plot it's just kind of
like a character trait where he's a
professor he's like in his 40s and he
just like bangs a series of 18 year olds
yeah and they all say the same thing
it's like you're nothing like my dad
it's just kind of like a funny train to
say that i can't sell it's just like a
weird one what's funny is that like the
the uh the other three guys in the in
the movie
all right um who are like the supporting
characters you got the lawyer the
scientist and the cia guy yeah they give
they give the backgrounds to all three
of them
and what's funny about them is that
today you wouldn't notice much anything
unusual about them but they would have
been unusual for the 70s
um
they were all good dudes but all kind of
flawed
and i guess they were just trying to say
that there's nobody
perfect in in the uh
in in the world or in any kind of
position
like the lawyer
um
he was a gay dude um living there and
that was and then they ended up well i
guess you could sit he ended up getting
killed his boyfriend did as well and his
wife that was one thing that i thought
was really interesting about this movie
that i've forgotten about was that
normal people yeah but by the 70s
standards and that they were achieving
great things
and then you had the uh the the
the they all had foibles and individual
qualities about them you know what i
mean which we were the 70s would have
been cutting edge to show this in a
movie
uh the gay aspect that would have been
cutting edge then they had the the
doctor and the doctor
or the scientists the scientists had a
thing for young girls now they weren't
underage
but yeah they were he was a college
professor he wasn't like banging 14 year
old he could have been making all this
money with these for these for these
universities but he was a sex addict
that was probably what yeah
how you would have
um
uh he'd had fetish for the uh
the kind of lolita fetish i guess you
could say that that's how you would have
described it today because he could have
been making all kinds of money
in the uh
in in the in the [ __ ] science
in the corporate [ __ ] world but he
gave all that up just to bang young
broads yeah basically
and then uh the cia guy was an
ex-military dude who was like they
showed pictures of him they all this
[ __ ] is happening in different and out
of order you got to put it together yeah
the show i'm in it's like in military
uniform he's like a low-ranking general
probably look like a brigadier general
or a lieutenant general
and uh he's made it he's rich he's a
[ __ ] black dude he's got this really
[ __ ] hot white wife and the mixed
family and uh but he's doing the dirty
work for these corporations yeah but
he's not a bad guy he's doing what he
thinks is right it's they're just
interesting characters and these would
have been very kind of
it wasn't usual to show that kind of
stuff in the 70s that
someone can have dualism that he's a
good man but he's kind of has to do bad
things
yeah because of a greater good because
they were afraid like
other court like competing corporations
as well as perhaps the government they
don't really like specify but is worried
about david bowie's company because he's
coming out with all this like amazing
technology
and kind of like disrupting the economy
in the sense like you said like the
whole planned obsolescence thing because
that was uh something that went on a lot
in the 70s no what i was gonna say like
a while back was that
the portrayal of the uh the lawyer
being in a committed relationship with
another man and not and them not making
a joke about it or not even
drawing attention to it i had actually
forgot about that kind of i was like wow
that was like really uh
really ahead of its time for the 70s
where no one commented on it nobody
nobody was like oh super swishy because
you know like in the 70s they always had
to like go over the top like even in
some movies like blacula and stuff like
that where it's like they all had to be
like oh my god girl they all had to be
like that it was like it was almost like
played for laughs whereas this was
played like completely normally the way
it would be played nowadays yeah and i
was just like thought that was like so
and it really wasn't underscored you had
to read it in between the lines that
they were a couple yeah nobody even said
i didn't realize until the time that i
didn't realize that there were a couple
until they got killed yeah and i was
like oh i didn't realize that those two
dudes were yeah
yeah because they didn't like overplay
it which they just made it seem like
completely normal which like i said was
really ahead of its time for 1976. i
don't think i saw another movie like
that and then the black dude
who was you know what i mean
played by bernie casey by the way yeah
he does a [ __ ] great job he wasn't
playing the [ __ ] butler or the
shoeshine boy or anything the
[ __ ] is the damn intel warlord
he's running all this [ __ ] yeah and that
that was that was pretty cool you know i
mean because that's probably how it
really would have been in the 70s with a
dude like that you know i mean there's
looking there's all these [ __ ]
powerful cia guys and [ __ ] [ __ ]
confirm with him and clearing it but
he's got this [ __ ] vast military
background and all this [ __ ]
professionalism and [ __ ] and he's like
great showing good leadership signs and
[ __ ] like j he's basically kind of like
a james bond yeah the military version
of james bond
which would have been that would have
been
that's that would have been an unusual
casting decision for the 70s yeah yeah i
mean they would have put a [ __ ] white
james bond dude in there but no it's
black dude yeah and like i said made it
a lot better and they don't but but it's
not but they don't draw attention to it
they don't just like they don't draw
attention to like the gay couple you
know like you said you didn't even
really realize it until like until the
end and i just thought that was really
like i said that was really really ahead
of its time yeah because you know me
having a military background i'm telling
you that's the way it really is yeah
that's what it really is [ __ ] it's
it's it's a meritocracy it's not about
what color you are [ __ ] was a
badass he was in charge yeah and and the
other guys are like yeah yes sir yeah
but i think that the fact of you know
bernie casey's character being a black
guy like the
lawyer being you know in a gay
relationship i think that whole thing
was kind of like underscoring even
though like i said it's not super
obvious because of the way the movie is
edited together um i think that was kind
of underscoring the whole uh theme of
the movie which like i said you know the
alien david bowie whose name is thomas
jerome newton by the way i don't know if
that was his alien name or just the name
that he took when he came to earth but
but him just being this kind of like
amazing interesting person with all
these cool ideas with who made all this
money um but then like he sort of by
earth life
the vapidity of it the wealth
accumulation he just kind of gets ground
down
to a point where he just becomes mundane
like everyone else like he gets in a
relationship with uh mary lou who's
played by candy clark who prior to this
had been an american graffiti and she
was in a [ __ ] ton of movies later she's
just like works at a motel that he stays
at or something and they just kind of
end up in this relationship
and
in in some way it's not her fault that
he ends up like that but because she's
just kind of like a regular
working-class girl she loves her gin
um and so he just kind of ends up
falling in with her they move in
together like he just sits there
watching tv and he starts drinking and
so it's almost kind of like he's
descending into
just this kind of like mundane lifestyle
but it almost kind of like sucks him in
well so do all the other guys didn't you
know yeah that's what i'm saying yeah
black dude towards the end was his hair
was all gray he was still doing the job
but he just wasn't into it like he was
before yeah you know same thing with the
lawyer
and the scientist so
time had taken its toll on all the
characters yeah which
that just goes along with the theme of
the movie that the world just sucks you
down grinds you down yeah it's just like
everything that was individual or
interesting about you um you know just
kind of slowly gets worn down over time
that really does seem like one of the
main themes which i don't agree with it
no it's not that's not the way life me
and jenny are [ __ ] jenny's coming up
in her 50s i'm in my 50s and [ __ ] no
you can remain relevant for a long long
time
um i know what they're talking about
people aged faster back then
and the world beat you up a lot harder
back then yeah and i do kind of feel
like i mean obviously i don't think the
movie's saying that happens to everybody
but they're just they're just you know
it can they're saying it can happen even
to the most interesting even from like a
dude that's like an alien from another
planet and it's like things happen to
him over the course of the movie where
like i said he ends up in this
relationship with i mean she's a she's a
lovely girl and she's not like a
[ __ ] or anything like that but she's
just kind of like a regular person small
town girl a small town kind of girl and
she's like from oklahoma or something
and it's you know it just shows how like
easy it is to kind of get sucked into
an easy lifestyle that's not all that
challenging and as the movie goes on he
kind of gets he picks up some of her bad
habits like drinking he gets like even
more secretive
and it's just kind of like he just wants
to sit around watching tv even though
he's yelling at it like it's just this
vapid thing that's like not telling you
or it doesn't mean anything but he still
can't stop watching it so it's kind of
like that and then as it really goes on
like toward the end he because at one
point i guess he has like a fake skin
they don't really like go into this very
much but i guess he has like a fake
human costume essentially um which is
which i think is like some kind of
biological thing because at some point
when he wants to show mary lou his
girlfriend like what he really looks
like he actually goes and like kind of
cuts his nipple and like pulls
everything off and then he doesn't like
he doesn't have nipples and he doesn't
have genitalia and he just has like
these crazy like yellow cat eyes and
no hair and no eyebrows and [ __ ] like
that so he's like really freaky looking
and um which you know david bowie pulls
off really well but as time goes on it
seems like the longer he's on earth and
you know and his wife and uh his wife
and kids are still back on that other
planet presumably being like gee wish he
would come back with that water because
they don't usually die they must have
because it had been they show like
through the aging of all the characters
like mary lou like ends up getting kind
of like pudgy and gray-haired and [ __ ]
like that so it's several years but he
doesn't get any older but as time goes
on it seems like they're doing like an
experiment on him where they're trying
to he's telling him hey look i'm an
alien and he wants to take the contacts
out but then they x-ray his eyes and
like fuses them so it's almost kind of
like it was taking him from
extraordinary to ordinary yeah he can't
it gets the appointment he can't take
the human suit off like he can't take
the human suit off anymore so he's like
not an alien anymore so like i said
everything interesting about him has
been kind of like whittled away by the
you know by the lameness of the world at
large i kind of feel like that's sort of
the message of the movie
but um but yeah so like i said this
movie
what ended up happening with it was that
as i said nicholas roeg having had a
large success with don't look now which
like i said if you haven't seen that we
reviewed it a long time ago that's one
of my favorite horror movies that's a
great [ __ ] horror movie um so they
you know
that was successful so they gave him
money to do this to do an adaptation of
the novel nicholas rugg decided hey i'm
gonna shake some [ __ ] up and he made
this
and uh the paramount was like we're not
paying for that because that wasn't what
we wanted
and the british production company
because i think this was actually an
entire british production company
entirely british crew even though they
shot the whole thing in the united
states and new mexico
so the british production company had to
sue paramount
to get some money back and i guess it
ended up going to the smaller production
company in the u.s that cut 20 minutes
out of it probably a lot of that 20
minutes was that scene near the end
where
uh where mary lou
who is you know she's older now and she
comes to visit him in this facility they
locked him away in
um and they have this crazy sex scene
where he's basically like shooting at
her with blanks and she's shooting at
him with blanks like right in their
[ __ ] faces
which
yeah she he shoots a blank on her tongue
like right in her face yeah i didn't see
what kind of pistol it was real clear i
think it was like a 455 wembley you know
and i [ __ ]
do not do that if you put a [ __ ]
blank fire pit up against anything pull
the trigger it'll blow it right off that
gas comes out of there ultrasonic it'll
just blow a hole right through you it
doesn't need to have a bullet yeah and
[ __ ] that should have been edited out
because you don't want to give people it
goddamn ideas an idea that that you can
just shoot a blank right in someone's
face and it's right in someone's ear and
it's okay no [ __ ] no it'll blow a hole
right through you just like it would
have just like there was a bullet yeah
because it's like right there yeah so
yeah
and it's a weird it's a weird like
extended scene you have them just
shooting blanks just shooting blanks
like right in each other's faces who
wrote this [ __ ]
yeah like yeah it's super bizarre so i
kind of feel like that was probably
taken out there's a lot of nudity in
this there's a lot of weird sex scenes
so i kind of feel like a lot of that was
probably taken out as well because like
i said the u.s cut was 20 minutes
shorter
but the version that's on amazon prime
now is is the actual
cut like the original cut that came out
in europe which is two hours and 20
minutes long european navy yes i think
only a european
at that time would have made a scene
showing blanks being used that way you
couldn't show that in america well like
i said it was it was a british
production it's a british room um you
know yeah no no yeah they just shot they
just like filmed it here that's that's
that's for people that don't think guns
are real
[ __ ] right they're all over the
united states so you cannot do that's
like it's just a chainsaw
here
it doesn't have the actual chain on it
but i'm gonna rub it right up against
your throat and see how that goes you
know
but yeah so how so how it ends up like i
said so he actually does make enough
money to build a spaceship
but it actually is not his fault cause
he actually is all suited up and he's
gonna go back to the planet like with
the water and everything and like i said
it's a big elon musk kind of moment
where it's like look it's a private
enterprise and it's going he's going up
to space and everything and uh it turns
out that his driver was a mole right um
from the cia other company people that
were like working so they actually kind
of
uh waylay him they like kidnap him and
then they lock him in this facility and
they basically just like do experiments
on him and keep them keep him drugged
and keep him drunk like you know and
just to keep him out of trouble
and so so we don't know how long that
goes on it's presumably quite a long
time because when mary lou comes back to
visit him she's like much older and much
fatter um so you know so probably it's
pretend she's much fatter well i know
they well they puffed her face out which
actually probably would happen if you
were as drunk as she was because she's
like like i said she was like drunk all
the time yeah and it's like they showed
their their house and it's just like
there's just gin bottles all over the
[ __ ] place and reality [ __ ] was
[ __ ] skinny and cute as [ __ ] she was
yeah do you know what i heard i was
watching mark carmode's uh discussion
about this movie i heard i think and i
don't know if this is true or not
because you know how skinny david bowie
is in this movie marker mode said that
he had actually that david bowie had to
gain 14 pounds for this role yeah which
i find that hard to believe because he's
real skinny in this movie he's just
cocaine's a hell of a drug it is yeah
and like i said he said he he said he
was super coked up on this movie
although the other actors like candy
clark who plays mary lou um she said he
was lovely she didn't seem she said he
didn't seem like he was coked up or
anything
but he says he was
but he said that probably helped because
he just acted like himself and he's like
and i felt kind of like an alien at that
point in my life so it probably worked
out
you know what i mean but in those days
cocaine was cheap as long as you had a
lot of it you could keep yourself cooked
up you'd never [ __ ] really and it was
you know it's not like smoking cracks
not quite as harsh so that's true they
lived like that they just it's an
appetite suppressant they just wouldn't
eat yeah well that's why everyone was so
[ __ ] scrawny in the center yeah the
quality was good by the compared to day
standards yeah back then you couldn't do
that today you'd all [ __ ] go broke
[ __ ] you just could afford it yeah i
feel like cocaine like the price of it
started going way up in the 80s and then
then it became like the yuppie drug and
then that's why everybody went to crack
because like cocaine was becoming too
expensive on a side thing we talked
about cocaine i know this is gonna be a
sidetrack evidently on some of those
islands where they have the cha the
children islands and everything they had
whole barrels of designer [ __ ] drugs
made from
their friends [ __ ]
drug companies real drug companies you
know
i don't they weren't named but they
could make analogs to cocaine uh that
you you can't find it on the street
they'll just make it for themselves
and it's that same effect but then after
a few hours you become repelled by it
so there so it stops working and it
keeps you from getting addicted to it
weird
interesting like a designer version of
cocaine yeah that
you can't get addicted to because after
a while you're just like no more
yeah yeah weird i believe it though but
everything there were a whole 55 oil
drums of it
found or not well you know big 55-gallon
drums
on uh
the island that had the man with the
children go ahead
but yeah so so i feel like what ends up
happening at the end like i said so they
kidnap him and then after a long time
that like i said the there's no
there's no um signposts really like how
much time has passed between each thing
happening because sometimes like i said
he lands and then suddenly he has a big
wad of cash um you're not really sure
where he got that from or how long it's
been since he landed or whatever so it's
it jumps ahead a lot so it's almost kind
of like this weird like disjointed like
i said you can follow it if you're
paying attention but you really have to
be paying attention so
he's at this facility or whatever with
all these people studying him for a
really long time but then i guess it's
been so long that everybody like nobody
works there anymore and they like forgot
about him um so he just leaves because
he's like oh it's unlocked so he just
leaves i guess because you know candy
clark or mary lou comes to visit him and
they're just kind of like okay bye and
then like he leaves and then he ends up
going and making an album like becoming
a rock star because he makes these this
album with like alien messages on it so
because he hopes that his wife will
still hear it somewhere um even though
presumably she's dead i mean they do
show a scene where she's where her and
the kids are dying of thirst but you
don't know if that's if that really
happened or if that's or if he's just
picturing that yeah because it's been a
really long time but we don't know what
their life span is because
obviously many many years have passed
because everybody else in the movie is
way older but david bowie still looks
the same because he like hooks back up
with uh you know one of the dudes that
was like worked for his company who has
since married mary lou and he's like
much older and he's like hey i heard
your record like i didn't really love it
or whatever and then
you know david bowie's just there like
drunk and the you know the uh waiter
comes over and just be like i think
you've had enough mr newton you know
what i mean so he apparently still has
all his money
um but he can't go back home now and
even if he does like his wife and kids
are probably dead so it's kind of like
so it's kind of like a bummer ending
because it's like he came here like all
full of promise and he was all crazy and
he had all these
cool like uh gadgets and patents and he
made billions and billions of dollars
and he's like yeah i'm gonna go back to
space and i'll have my own space program
and [ __ ] like that but you know the
world just ground him down in the end
and now he's just like this sad
dude sitting at a cafe drinking
in the middle of the day and it's just
kind of and his family's probably dead
on some distant planet and he's probably
never gonna get back home and it's so
it's just like a really really sad but
like i said i you know i feel like this
is definitely
one of those movies that it comes up on
a lot of people's you know uh best
sci-fi movies list and i can see that
but like i said it's very very
experimental
um it's not a real
it has a plot but it's very
strange the editor is [ __ ] yeah the
edit of it is very strange um the
timeline of it is very strange um so
you're not really sure but it's one of
those movies where it has like some
really cool visuals david bowie is
always worth watching um but like you
said i kind of feel like if david bowie
wasn't in this
then
i don't know if it would have been the
same or if it would have been as
memorable i don't think so just because
david bowie like the way he comes across
in this because he's always i mean just
as a person he always seemed like so
unearthly anyway so i always even though
he wasn't the first choice for this role
i mean i think it was really good that
he ended up in this because he really
brings
he really brings an alienness to the
role you can totally buy that he's not
from this planet what holds this back is
the edit
nowadays you'd have to have a a lot
peppier
edit with a lot more excitement in it
and and drama and like why is he going
to get out is going to get it done but
that would eliminate a lot of the movie
because it's kind of a simple story
that's a problem
um
another thing that that's about it is
that it tries to weird you out with
things that today would be pretty
commonplace
yeah he's an alien which isn't his fault
which isn't the movie's fault because
that time has passed yeah yeah and
that's the thing and that's kind of the
shitty thing about like seeing a lot of
things from the 70s which like i said in
the context of the 70s this was actually
like kind of mind-blowing because a lot
of the [ __ ] that was in this movie
hadn't really been done or hadn't been
done in that way before but because
so much stuff came afterward and
everybody's seen that so threshold
change yeah so it doesn't seem as you
know experimental or as crazy or arty or
something like that as that as it did
back then
um and i didn't even see this because
obviously i was only four when this came
out but i probably saw it
i feel like i probably saw it in the 80s
and i remember thinking it was pretty
weird then like and not what i was
expecting and i'm pretty sure that i saw
like the cut up version like with the 20
minutes cut out of it yeah like the idea
that a guy
that a guy is actually an alien dressed
up as a human that's not that weird
that the uh the idea that a guy makes
enough money that he buys his own space
program they got dudes that do that you
know yeah that's what i mean in the 70s
that was like holy that was a big deal
dude has his own space program yes no no
way that's not possible yeah but yeah it
is we now know that that is possible
and that they can do it better than nasa
a lot better than this
do you know that uh michael fassbender
uh playing david in prometheus uh used
this character like
david bowie's character as kind of like
a linchpin you know or jumping off point
for what he was doing yeah uh in this
yeah so he he said he used that as a as
inspiration which i thought was kind of
uh interesting but yeah so
so as weird as this movie is it has had
like a really large uh cultural impact
there have been like other movie
references to it to that character um
you know all kind of [ __ ] like that so
whether you love the movie or not it's i
mean it's definitely culturally relevant
and like i said especially for the time
some of the stuff they put in this movie
in the 70s
um
i was like watching it again i was
actually really surprised at how like
ahead of its time it was yeah um also i
think the you know the guns n roses
video uh welcome to the jungle i think
they they used like some kind of imagery
homaging this movie
uh from there too oh and i was watching
this interview
with i guess in the 2000
like the 2015 somewhere around there
they actually did an off-broadway
musical called lazarus which was based
on this
and um michael c hall the dude that
plays dexter plays the david bowie
character because he's real into like
off-broadway he was in hedwig in the
angry inch and a bunch of other stuff um
but yeah so and i've heard it was like
really really awesome but i i don't know
if it's like a remake or if it's like a
continuation
but i would i don't know i was just like
watching an interview with him and i was
like that kind of sounded pretty cool
but you know i don't know we'll see and
i think in the 80s too i think they did
like a tv series or a tv movie that was
another adaptation of this but i haven't
seen that and i don't imagine it's very
good because i never hear anybody bring
it up everybody brings up this movie
because it's like weird as [ __ ] and like
i said david bowie's in it but
i don't know like like i said
it's on amazon prime if you have amazon
prime you can watch it for free if you
have two hour two and a half hours and
you want to see like some weird 70s
oh i want to say sort of borderline
incomprehensible but you can kind of
follow it but you just have to pay
attention it's in it's an important
movie from a cultural aspect it is yeah
you know about
who david bowie was and
what
a certain opinion of what a 70s american
corporate corporate culture was like
it's still kind of like that not as it's
changed some but
some of the concepts are still there
yeah like this is the only show i i've i
know of that ever came out and talked
about planned obsolescence and
disruptive technologies no other no
other movie ever mentioned that and that
was a reality in this well i think they
did but it's like this is the only one
that i could think of offhand i mean i'm
sure there were probably some other
company would have an invention they
said man this is a badass invention we
can we'll we'll beat all the [ __ ] you
know we will beat all the
uh uh competition if we come out with
this but you know what
we could sell this model and this model
and this model first and make all that
money and then eventually replace it
with this one
so they were controlling the they were
doing that but see i think jump right to
that ultimate model they'd miss out
on the other money that they wanted you
to buy all of them well i mean i
remember people i don't know i'm sure it
was in a movie but i remember people
talking about that in the 70s yeah
particularly as in regards to cars and
things yeah i remember my family talking
about it i remember people on tv talking
about it so it's kind of so i'm sure it
turned up in other movies but you know
what though it was a conspiracy theory
back then but it was true and granters
will tell you about it because you know
we grew up partially in the detroit auto
industry area in trenton michigan and
we had friends and family members that
worked for the ford and gm and that was
definitely part of the plan at the
executive level
well yeah i mean they want you to like
buy a new car
well honestly in all the cars in the 50s
they were even being pretty blatant uh
with because you know i've seen some of
those um you know
car new cars of the year whatever like
shorts like they do a lot of them on mst
and they would pretty much come out and
be like you know hey in two years you
buy a new car so they were like really
open about it every two years you'd buy
another car yeah but the if you went to
a place like mississippi or florida
and you asked a person you told them you
know do you think that they would
you know
do you do you think that planned
obsolescence is a real thing they go no
no they're giving you the best that they
have at that time no they're not they
had that [ __ ] planted out in those
[ __ ] steps over ten years five years
so you were the the the buying public
was five ten years behind what they
actually had planned
and they would have said that that was a
conspiracy theory but no and if you grew
up in the down river area in michigan
where everybody's friend and family were
involved in the [ __ ]
auto industry at the executive levels no
you knew exactly they knew it was coming
they were going to make all those money
along the way on those little steps
yeah so that was kind of a big plot
point in this movie was that because he
came from outer space and he had like
all this kick-ass technology he was
[ __ ] all that and he was [ __ ]
everything up so they had to like take
him out disruptive technology jumps way
ahead and makes everybody obsolete and
all these people have money and power
and the banking system get pissed and
they send governments after you
also which lets you know that oligarchs
run the government they the government
only serves the oligarchs that's like
their lap dogs and that's exactly
they talked about that too and that was
true also two fun facts in this uh is
that apparently christopher nolan when
he was making the prestige uh wanted to
cast david bowie as nikola tesla because
specifically of his role in this movie
because he said nikola tesla also seemed
like a man out of his time or who'd come
from outer space also and i didn't even
realize this when i was watching the
movie you know candy clark who plays uh
mary lou yeah she also plays the alien
wife oh i didn't realize it but i didn't
realize that because she has so much
like she looks like an alien uh so i
didn't even realize that was her
but that is also her thematically it
made sense he had an earth wife and an
alien wife because i think she even says
to him at one point like asked about his
wife and is like is she anything like me
and he says no
but that was the same and she asked her
what about the children he goes mike
what about your mar your alien children
he goes they're just like children
they're exactly like children that that
line made me laugh out loud
because she was asking what his children
were like and it's like he almost seemed
like he didn't even understand that
question yeah he's like they're just
children children aren't like anything
they're like children
they're exactly like children
that just like made me laugh i just
really really liked that line but yeah
so yeah this is a weird ass movie if you
are into sci-fi at all or into like
experimental 70s movies then you owe it
to yourself to check this one out like i
said it's it's an easier movie i think
to appreciate its cultural significance
rather than enjoy it because it's a very
strange
movie um but i definitely think that if
you're into film at all particularly
sci-fi you should probably see it
because yeah it did have a lot of things
in it is it a good relevant no no it's
not a good movie uh it's well shot
it looks cool david bowie looks great
there's a lot of good acting in it
it's got a weird [ __ ] edit there's a
bunch of [ __ ] they could have done but i
guess couldn't afford it
it could have been done a lot better
but even if you even if you trimmed it
down into something a little more
streamlined i think a lot of the movie
would have been gone at that point
because the story isn't that complicated
it's more like an experience than it is
anything else
yeah i think that's a good way of
putting it it's not a
good movie but it's uh
it's an important movie i guess that'd
be a way to say it in a certain way and
you mean i mean i i don't know if i'd
say it's not a good movie i'm just
saying it's not one that you'd like put
on to like just sit back and enjoy no
it's more like an intellectual exercise
kind of yeah more
shot well yeah it looks cool it's got a
lot of cool interior and exterior shots
uh the acting's pretty good uh everybody
looks [ __ ] good and it's got some
really good ideas uh
so the quality is high i'm not saying
it's low quality the quality is pretty
high it's definitely a 70s art film oh
yeah that oh that oh that's a strike
against it because those things [ __ ]
suck
just like it did um
they were
but you have to remember about nothing a
lot of times but this did have a lot
going for is one of the best of its
types yeah well and you have to respect
that you know in the 60s and 70s
filmmakers were busting out of this
little box yeah that filmmaking had been
put into and was like you know we want
to do something different and even if
you tried to do something different and
you failed i would rather you do
something different than just do the
same old same old again and this is
definitely not same old same old no it
is unusual it is a very strange movie
but like i said i'll watch that over
like a boring formulaic movie anything
of the week so just saying uh but yeah
so that'll do it for this movie
retrospective on the man who fell to
earth from 1976.
uh we will see you on the next one
bye